hello everybody and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll and today we're going to talk
about space travel one of the things
that you don't necessarily appreciate
when you start talking about space
travel is the very different scales that
we might be talking about so we're not
talking about traveling to other stars
today anyway we're not even talking
about the very down to earth mission of
taking a gigantic rocket and launching
it into space to put up human beings or
satellites
well we'll be talking about is once you
get there once you're out in space let's
say you're in orbit around the earth how
do you move around the big problem with
space travel is carrying weight carrying
mass up into space and if you rely on
conventional methods of propulsion once
you're up there that means you eat an
awful lot of fuel just to adjust your
position in orbit so today's guest
Natalia Bailey is an aerospace engineer
who has started a new company called
accion systems that's AC cion it's named
after a spell in Harry Potter not after
the hypothetical small particle that
could be the dark matter but acción
systems is doing our building ion drive
engines if you're of a certain age like
I am you remember ion drives as being
this way that you might investigate
interstellar travel because an ion drive
can provide a small amount of propulsion
but for a very long time with very
little fuel being wasted so accion
systems is building these incredibly
tiny you know centimeter sized rocket
engines that can be put on to little
tiny satellites like cube sets that you
and your educational institution could
build and launch into space yourselves
and then they will help you move them
around from place to place this is going
to be an important part of a burgeoning
ecosystem where we have a lot of new
satellites in space that hopefully will
not be crashing into each other and
hopefully will be organizing themselves
in the most efficient way it's also a
stepping stone of course once you're in
space at all once you're in orbit you're
halfway to anywhere you're halfway to
Mars you're halfway to Pluto or whatever
so this is going to be an important way
that we advance the cause of traveling
through the solar system in much more
efficient ways so this is a great
conversation that we did
you know Tony and I are both
science-fiction fans ourselves so near
the end of the talk we forget about the
solar system and think more broadly
about traveling through space I do want
to apologize because the audio quality
on this one fades near the end it's fine
at the beginning but the last 15 minutes
are a little rougher I tried to clean
them up as much as I could you know
these podcasts some of them I do at my
house or in my office others I do
remotely I will travel to somebody
else's place or at some conference or
something some of them you got to do
over the computer right and that's the
the biggest challenge I've been
investigating different software
different websites different services to
do this sometimes they work really well
sometimes not as well I apologize to the
listeners in to Natalia that this time
didn't work as well but I'm trying to
get better at it still new at this and I
think that I'm getting better at it so
hopefully this is a temporary glitch the
content of the discussion is really
really great so I think you're going to
enjoy this let's go
[Music]
Vitaliy belly welcome to the mindscape
podcast thanks for having me John so
there's obviously we all know that the
orbits above us the sky above us are is
filled with satellites I think maybe
people don't really have a very good
idea of how densely packed the space is
with satellites or how not densely
packed we're hearing about the fact that
there's a lot of space debris up there
but on the other hand the space is
really big right and you know you can
have a lot of things up there without
any of them running into each other you
just like set the stage for us a bit and
what is the current environment up there
in near-earth orbit and Beyond sure so
as far as the the earth orbiting
satellites that are focused down here at
people living on our planet every year
they're you know around a thousand
spacecraft launched that number has
increased from the previous kind of
space industry how we've done things for
the past 50 years it's been increasing
every year for the past decade I think
we'll probably start to see numbers more
like three thousand five thousand
spacecraft launched annually so now all
of those things last anywhere from you
know a few months on orbit all the way
to 15 or 20 years on orbit and you said
so you can you know do that math and
figure out how many of those are up
there but the other thing that that has
people in this community a bit worried
is that sometimes satellites collide
with one another or hit another object
in space and and they themselves turn
into you know ten thousand new pieces of
debris and that that can actually have a
kind of waterfall sort of effect called
the Kessler syndrome where potentially
we could reach a point where there are
just so many pieces of this debris in
orbit that but the problem kind of runs
away and we keep creating more and more
debris and low-earth orbit becomes a bit
unusable for for these earth facing
applications so we're keeping an eye on
that but like I said the number per
years you know about a thousand and
growing and it's an exciting time in the
industry yeah I bet that most people
because me didn't realize that the
lifespan was only 10 or 15 years so that
means that a thousand satellites are
falling to earth every year right yeah
that's about right and is that just is
that lifespan specific to near Earth
orbit low Earth orbit I mean how should
we in our brains visualize the different
places that we put these out that's a
great question so a satellite launch to
about I think it's you know 300 or so
kilometers will stay there for about a
year a satellite launched to 500
kilometers could stay there for about 20
years and it's actually an exponential
relationship with altitude between
altitude and lifetime so is if you go
much above 500 kilometers and that's the
distance above the earth you end up
basically putting things there that for
for the all reasonable purposes end up
becoming kind of permanent fixtures
which is not not a great position to be
in
so really the UN and then NASA and
various space agencies prefer that
things only have about a 20 to 25 year
lifetime in orbit so that either means
500 kilometers and below or that these
objects have a way to do orbit
themselves at the end of their useful
life time and presumably they burn up in
the atmosphere there's not a threat that
they're going to land in San Francisco
and hurt people right yeah I think I
believe I read somewhere that you're
more likely to be attacked by a shark
and struck by lightning in the same day
than then you are to be hit by a piece
of debris from a spacecraft if I take
that statistic seriously I presume that
means that no one has ever been hit by
for you for the spacecraft okay good I
didn't realize that you know NASA and
the space agencies actually encouraged
people to launch their satellites into
lower Earth orbits specifically so they
don't last so that part of the solution
to the problem of over cluttering orbit
is make it temporary yes exactly
things only become really problematic if
they're up there for you know 5 10 15
years otherwise they they do orbit on
their own and of course there's the
special geosynchronous orbits where you
orbit once every 24 hours you can you
can hang out above some particular place
on earth or at least some particular
latitude sorry longitude on earth but
that's much further out right yeah
exactly
much further out much more expensive to
reach so that's more for the you know
handful of fortune 500 companies and
then the the space agencies and that's
you know roughly 40,000 kilometers
versus the kind of 400 we've been
talking about okay and how and the
environment there in terms of what
satellites are up there is changing
obviously we have communication
satellites we have Defense Department
stuff and NASA stuff but these days it's
becoming a lot cheaper right to just
send something into space yes exactly so
the past I guess now maybe 15 years
you've had this fantastic combination of
private money and coming into the space
industry and then Moore's law making
smaller electronics still quite capable
and and now we're able to package those
into smaller spacecraft you have this
ever-increasing demand for the Internet
and so these various factors have come
together and space has as a result
become more accessible and also more
desirable for various applications and
you know more more affordable so smaller
satellites mean that more countries can
access space more organizations
you know we're working with a high
school team and they're also you know
hobbyists in their garage building
satellites which I will never stop
feeding beautified but these is this the
CubeSat idea explain to us what a
CubeSat is and why it's so fun sure a
CubeSat is kind of the one industry
attempt at a more standard form factor
for a satellite so as you know or can't
imagine standardized anything basically
can lead to reduce costs and and
therefore more users around the world
being able to leverage spacecraft so it
CubeSat one cube one unit is 10
centimeters by 10 centimeters by 10
centimeters so a thousand centimeters
cubed and to give you a more physical
sense you could fit a softball inside of
one you what's a little bit more popular
as a 3u so that looks a little bit more
like a shoebox or a champagne bottle and
there are actually commercial companies
now launching three u cube sets that are
able to generate revenue which is you
know an extremely new thing in the in
the past decade and yes you mentioned
high schools how much does it cost if I
let's say I have built the CubeSat
let's say I'm not very good at it I just
built it at home but I trust it's gonna
go up there how much would it cost me to
get it on a rocket and launch into orbit
if you are a high school you know all in
you're probably spending twenty to forty
thousand if if you're an individual or a
commercial business you're spending
maybe one hundred fifty two hundred
thousand dollars you mean they charge me
more because of an individual not a high
school yes there are a lot of discounted
launch opportunities for academic
projects I see well a hundred thousand
dollars is probably outside my price
range for building my personal vanity
satellite yeah exactly that's right in
and the when you say that there are
companies doing the launches so they're
building rockets obviously we hear about
NASA launches we hear about SpaceX and
Blue Origin and so forth but how many
companies are there launching things
into space so you'll have to fact-check
me on these numbers but in something
like 2008 I believe there were around 80
active space companies and then 2018
there were something like 800 and now
some some of those are not the ones
actually sending things into space but
they're part of the the value chain
somewhere so that gives you a sense of
the the growth in recent years okay yeah
no I really had no idea and are they
launching from their home base or do
they do they rent you know space it Cape
Canaveral or something yeah there are a
few launch sites around the world the
you know the ones I hear most about are
people launching from India on their
launch vehicle you know in the US
there's there's the Cape like you
mentioned and then on the west coast
there's Vandenberg
there's also Wallops but that's off the
coast of Virginia but that tends to be
more of the government launches and then
they're you know our first launch was
from New Zealand so that's a new thing
for the industry okay yeah that's cool I
mean it make sense to have it didn't
near the ocean right in case something
goes terribly wrong
yes exactly Range Safety they call it so
try not to fly over children and homes
and things like that and what are most
of these satellites doing these
thousands of satellites that are going
into orbit every year a couple main main
missions probably the most prevalent one
is communication so whether that is you
know Direct TV or Sirius Radio 2
broadband internet to IOT type of
services those all fall under
communications the other main segment is
Earth Observation or imaging
so using you know various spectral
imagers to infer things about the planet
for you know national security or
climate agriculture asset tracking
things like that and then of course you
have some of the the pure science
missions looking at the the atmosphere
looking at you know icebergs melting
doing other types of Earth and
atmospheric science and then some will
separate out maybe military applications
but really they can be a combination or
one of those three types that I already
mentioned right and I presume that most
of the high school ones are trying to do
some science or are they trying to do
communications yeah most are doing
science one of the ones we worked with
was taking pictures of Venus okay that's
cool so it's not just looking at the
earth they can look at they can make
their own little Space Telescope and
send it into orbit yeah exactly
all right I do not know that okay you've
mentioned your own satellites but you're
not so much in the satellite business as
you are in the little rocket engine
business right so once these satellites
are up there you may be happy with where
they're located or hether orbiting but
you might also want to push them around
and that's where you come in is that
right yes that's right so a very typical
use case for one of our systems is you
launch it launch your satellite but
maybe you had to purchase it a cheaper
sooner launch so it's not quite where
you wanted to go or you weren't put
precisely where you need it to be so you
need a propulsion system to raise or
lower your orbit initially if you launch
a group of satellites you also don't
want them to stay clustered together in
a very tight group so you need to phase
those out along an orbit then you know
presumably your mission lasts for five
seven fifteen years there are all sorts
of forces acting on a spacecraft when
it's in orbit
especially over that long of a period of
time there's gravity and atmospheric
drag and other perturbations you may
need to avoid collisions with debris
like we talked about
all sorts of reasons over the lifetime
you may need to maneuver and then at the
end of your satellites lifetime you're
responsible for making sure it D orbits
responsibly and Brynn's up in the
atmosphere so you also need propulsion
for that okay so what do people usually
do these days and what is the what is
most difficult kind of propulsion you
would hook up to your little satellite
well the status quo of industry frankly
has still been really large satellites
and and there are existing ion engines
we we build a type of ion engine there
are really large ion engines that work
on a on a geo satellite but those don't
scale down and so the the new industry
forming around smaller satellites
doesn't really have a solution today
there are several people trying to scale
down the traditional large technologies
to fit on small satellites those have
some kind of fundamental plasma physics
limitations that that we could get into
and then as a as a kind of back-up plan
it's possible to use a type of chemical
propulsion so like a smaller same
technology as a rocket for a launch but
a much smaller version those are not
very fuel-efficient which is why they're
not very popular or you could even do
something like a can of compressed air
and open that and use that thrust but
that's kind of the least efficient
method so those have been backup plans
but you really need something that's
much more fuel efficient to close a lot
of these so close basically all of these
business models and make these missions
viable right yeah we let's get into this
a little bit I mean I think the can of
compressed air is a hilarious way to
push your satellite around but I think
probably most people have in mind a
traditional chemical propulsion where
you burn some fuel and push yourself
around compare what is an ion engine
compare to that what's the very idea of
an ion engine sure so chemical rockets
that most people think of when they
think of rocket science or propulsion
the you know fundamentally you are
releasing chemical energy by breaking
bonds through combustion
and transferring that chemical energy
into kinetic energy to push the
spacecraft so you have let's say
hydrogen and oxygen and you combust
those two fuels fuel and oxidizer
together you end up with a very hot gas
as a result and that is forced through a
nozzle and out the back of the
spacecraft and the spacecraft moves in
the opposite direction so that's
chemical propulsion and you know
fundamentally that's that's based on the
conservation of momentum stuff out the
back pushes the spacecraft forward so
electric propulsion which is what we do
based on based also on conservation and
momentum stuff out the back pushes it
forward but we use electrical energy to
accelerate a charge particle out the
back of the spacecraft
so electrical into kinetic rather than
chemical into kinetic and it's actually
more efficient to do electrical into
kinetic in terms of the unit mass
however use you need your own power
source when you're doing the electrical
conversion chemical carries the power
required within the the reaction and so
there's there is a trade-off there and
it's also a bit slower so you send fewer
fewer particles with mass out the back
so you need more time on orbit to
accumulate to get up to the speed set
that you would like to reach but we've
found that most people in in the
industry actually have that time
available and would trade it to benefit
from the fuel efficiency savings so the
very very basic idea is you just charge
up an atom you ionize it and then you
put it in a strong electric field and
push it so instead of burning some fuel
you just take some atoms they're lying
around or molecules I don't know
hopefully you'll tell me and then you
can just accelerate them as long as you
have electricity and a
or electrical power source lying around
yes that's right and so this the idea of
an ion engine
I remember reading for the least in the
70s this was going to get us to
interstellar space but the technology
already exists that pre-exists that
predates your company that but you're
just doing a different spin on it yeah
that's right ion engines have been used
on commercial spacecraft and on
interplanetary spacecraft but they it's
near impossible to scale down this
particular particular technology to fit
on a smaller satellite so what kind of
technology is it that they use on the
big ones so conventional ion engine
works by injecting a neutral gas into an
ionization chamber so they'll inject
xenon or argon into a chamber and
they'll also inject a stream of
high-energy electrons and the the job of
those electrons is to find and collide
with one of those neutral atoms and to
kick off an electron there by ionizing
the xenon atom so now you have a xenon
ion and then some fraction of those
xenon ions hopefully makes it to the
downstream grid where there's actually
two grids and there's an electric field
between them so if an ion gets you know
finds its way into this electric field
its accelerated out the back of the
spacecraft producing thrust okay I see
so there I can already even though I'm a
theoretical physicist not an engineer I
can detect the possibility for some
inefficiencies in this initial process
where you're just squirting gas into a
chamber and ionizing yes so even even at
the larger scales there are several
inefficiencies you're losing ions into
the walls all the time and then as you
you could also imagine as you tried to
scale this technology down the first
thing you do is you make that ionization
chamber smaller because it has to fit on
a smaller spacecraft and what you've
essentially done is reduced the amount
of time the residence time that the the
neutral xenon atoms and those electrons
spend in that chamber so you've reduced
the likelihood that they'll collide with
one another
and so you basically don't form any ions
if you make the chamber small enough so
to combat that you have to increase that
likelihood again and so you inject more
high-energy electrons into the chamber
to improve your odds but now you have so
many high-energy electrons and and many
of them end up going right into the
walls of the chamber and to get back to
that same ionization fraction you
actually put so many into the walls that
you melt most materials known to man
that that could be used in this
application so it actually doesn't
really close on many of these the scales
of these smaller satellites okay so your
your company's devoted accion right is
that how we pronounce your company's
name yes it's it sounds exactly like a
particle physics hypothetical Dark
Matter candidate so but it's spelled
differently right yeah but you say you
are devoted to having a better
technology that can be made smaller and
more portable for the ion engine idea
yes so we can't get away from
conservation of momentum and we know
that we want that would be bigger news I
would have had you on the podcast
earlier a different different podcast
yeah and we know that we want to use
electrical energy to accelerate charged
particles out the back of the spacecraft
so those things hold but how can we
maybe get away from this ionization
probability and needing to inject this
gas and these electrons so we looked at
using instead a liquid propellant it's
called an ionic liquid actually and
they're quite popular in the battery and
electrochemical cell applications and
they're really just positive and
negative ions that happen to be liquid
over a wide range of temperatures
they're not in solution there's no water
or anything it's just positive and
negative ions so we we took these
liquids and we said well can we apply
this same electric field that those ion
engine guys apply between their grids to
accelerate their ions but can we not
only accelerate ions can we also extract
ions of one polarity out of this liquid
and then accelerate them with that same
potential with that same electric field
and it turns out that if you are clever
with the way
you kind of orient the geometries and
designing systems you can and so you
don't we don't need to ionize anything
on orbit we already have positive and
negative ions so we don't need this
large chamber for these collisions to
occur in we just really need that grid
and this source of ion then the reason
is you know we my co-founder and I were
we actually met as grad students in a
lab and weren't necessarily we don't
have entrepreneurial aspirations at the
time but the reason this that there was
this need for this and there was great
timing was this is actually inherently
happening on a very small scale this I
on a mission from these liquids occurs
within a region of about 20 nanometers
and so instead of taking something
really large and trying to scale it down
and basically tanking the efficiency we
started with this mechanism which
happens on a small scale and now we can
just paralyze it and scale it up to be
able to work on satellites of all sizes
I see ok and so the the the main
difference here is that in the chemical
propulsion the actual propellant is the
same thing as the fuel right I mean you
burn it and then you expel it whereas
here you will carry around this little
liquid of ions it's sort of it sort of
pre ionized in some sense that I guess
different kinds of ions gently hugging
each other and you know part yeah and
then but separately you have a source of
power which is electricity so do you
carry a battery up there or do you is it
solar-powered typically so we yeah we we
draw power from the spacecraft so a
combination of solar energy and
batteries ok and so oh is that the limit
is basically how much fuel you can bring
up the limit for how much thrust you
have over the lifetime of the satellite
yes that's right and and how long do you
have is it I mean you're packing these
into you know centimeters sized or you
know tens of centimeters sized boxes how
much lifetime can you have for pushing
yourself around yes well that that you
just nailed the big the most important
metric a taxi on right now
we've you know we've demonstrated that
the technique works now to make it
actually useful to various types of
missions and customers with satellites
lifetime is is the key here so when we
spun out of our lab we were operating
for 10 hours 20 hours recently we just
broke a thousand hours and that's
actually what we're now we're ready to
go to market with that so it's a on the
order of thousands of hours okay that's
cool and these are just so our audience
is visualizing this these rocket engines
are really tiny things right yes so we
have we build a complete system with the
the thruster head where the ions are
extracted and accelerated but also the
propellant supply system including the
tank and then the the power electronics
for interfacing with the spacecraft but
the the thruster head itself where all
of the magic occurs is we build it in
thruster chips and each chip is a square
centimeter and you can arrange any
number of these trips together in
different places on a spacecraft to
accomplish your mission so it's a square
centimeter and it's thinner in the in
the third dimension right it's Sanders
yeah okay so you basically like glue
these to the walls of your engine and
that's your rocket yeah to the walls of
your satellite right alright that is a
very cool idea and has it happened yet
have you are you in orbit yes well when
we were still at MIT we launched a
couple back in 2015 and just recently
accion launched our first two at the end
of last year and now we're working on
another three launches this year so yes
but you you're hoping to do a thousand
launches here I presume or yes exactly
that's a growing it's a booming thing
yep and how much thrust are we getting
out of this is this like a G or you know
it's probably a tiny little amount I'm
guessing tiny little amount each chip
produces about 12 and a half
two-fifty micronewtons so on the lower
end of that that's about the as much as
a mosquito landing on your hand
but you keep it up for hundreds or
thousands of hours and you can actually
move the satellite around is the idea
right yes and and when you're in space
and not you know trying to get out of a
gravity well or trying to compete
against atmospheric drag the the force
really adds up and and we're producing
enough thrust to complete most
commercial missions today so yeah just
to be super clear because I know it's
clear to me in you but for everyone
nothing you're doing is solving the
issue of getting into orbit right you
are not launching the spacecraft you're
gluing your little centimeter sized
tiles onto the size of something that's
already in orbit and and nudging it from
one orbit to another right we're doing
in space propulsion so the satellite has
already been launched and then we take
over from there and that's always going
to be true right there's no version of
this that's going to help us get into
space that's not the idea they're
they're universes where that's possible
where nuclear or some other you know
antimatter type of energy source is
available to power a system like this
right now political politically I don't
think that will be possible but as far
as the physics go it's not it's not
impossible
I see so basically because is the
limitation just how strong of an
electric field you can have or is it how
much fuel you can carry around no
actually for a launch the the current
limitation is in the power supply system
so the specific power power per kilogram
most power sources that people feel
comfortable launching from a country
with people living in it are - that
numbers too low the power per kilogram
is is too low but there are you know
there
there are possibilities where you could
launch small things with with known
power sources or with some more
theoretical ones in the future and if I
heard that people are imagining like 3d
printing launch systems that that will
get us into space how how close are we
to a truly revolutionary new
relationship with getting things into
orbit and manipulating them there yeah I
think I mean even today some of the new
launch companies are 3d printing a lot
of the main components or they're
innovating around having purely electric
pumps things like that so we're getting
there in terms of the components then
there are things like operational
considerations how do you build a
factory around this when your demand is
quite lumpy or uncertain and then I mean
it's a it's a bit of a chicken and egg
problem if they could be guaranteed you
know five thousand launches per year we
could start seeing a lot a lot of
innovation on the launch side if we
could be guaranteed you know five
hundred dollars a kilogram to orbit we
could see more innovation on the the
satellite side so fortunately we have
some really rich people that like
launching stuff into space working on
these problems so I think we're heading
in the right direction and that's not
you you're not one of those you're the
you know plucky little upstart yeah
exactly
and I presumed because it's in space
like everything in space there's a lot
of Defense commercial or customers I
guess I mean there's a lot of
applications for existing people I know
that just this morning I read an article
where India was able to shoot down a
satellite and so that they're now the
fourth country that has officially been
able to shoot down a satellite and it
makes you think about the future of the
militarization of space yes so right now
about half of of the market is its
government or military and you know
space in in the
jeez 60s to 90s was a big asset for for
spacefaring countries now it's kind of
flipped into a liability and we're so
dependent on it but now it doesn't it's
not a rare place that only a few people
can access so how do we protect the
things we're so dependent on now up
there and yeah I think you know the the
government and military side of that
will change a lot in the in the coming
years and there's a lot of a lot of
things happening you know if you're
following the you know space force and
the things happening in the Pentagon
versus what's happening in the Air Force
and a lot of a lot of changes right now
yeah well I'm not really following it I
mean are there so for the audience's
they're specific changes that we should
be looking out for even if they're not
you know set in stone but just what
kinds of things are people contemplating
yeah so the the Air Force has
traditionally been where most of the USS
space activity as far as defense has
been housed under and the the point I
made earlier about it becoming you know
a place we're trying to figure out how
to protect our assets and means that now
the Pentagon is considering creating a
separate branch of the military for
space specifically in recognition of
that and so their their moves happening
like that in some reorganizations as the
u.s. tries to navigate our next you know
a couple decades in space and I can't
help but think you know as a someone
who's trained as an astronomer one of
the great things to do in space is to
explore other planets are your engines
going to be useful for that kind of
thing either getting you know once
you're in orbit getting to other planets
or once they're there manipulating the
orbits of satellites and probes that
NASA might want to launch yeah
absolutely so honor on our roadmap is
increasing the amount of thrust or power
we can produce per unit area and
fortunately the particular technology
we're working on has a
potential to be scaled along those lines
in ways that are unlike any other
electric system that's known today
whether it's flight proven or
theoretical so we have this this
technology has legs and we can certainly
see it being used on you know crude
spaceflight missions or interplanetary
science missions in the future
especially as we continue to improve
that metric the thrust per unit area
does it make sense to sort of use
conventional fuel rockets to get into
space and then use ion engines to guide
yourself to Mars or something like that
yeah until we solved that that power per
kilogram issue we were talking about
earlier will continue to use chemical
rockets for launch from a gravity well
which is a planet or a massive planet so
we'll continue to do that and then use
more efficient means once were in space
I mean how do you personally see the
future in the sense you know we're there
was this space raised in the 60s and 70s
we went to the moon and that was very
exciting but now the United States
correct me if I'm wrong here we can't
even get a person into space right now
right as a country we don't have that
capability yeah so well right I mean we
do send up US astronauts but not on our
own rockets
so looking looking a little bit farther
ahead I think you know there's a big
question is is Mars the answer is the
moon the answer is our stations in
between planets the answer and I have my
own opinion which is that it's a bit
risky to plant yourself in another
gravity well once you make it off of one
so I mean that if you get off of the
planet Earth it's probably worthwhile
considering building an orbiting station
maybe at a around the earth or something
at a Lagrange point and I think I would
be I would change my mind
but more on that if there were planets
that we didn't need to go terraform or
that had really wonderful atmospheres
and we're more homely feeling for us
we're quite frail so I think being able
to design and curate our environment a
little bit more will be a more feasible
next step I like that would you call the
gravity well the rest of us call a
planet but yeah it doesn't have to be a
planet right yes that's right if it does
I get your point especially people who
seem sanguine about the idea of
terraforming Mars
it seems always very unrealistic to me
but we're not even very good at
controlling the climate of our own
planet right here on earth yeah I I
always come back to that too and I I
don't necessarily view it as a like oops
we messed up this one let's go find a
different one but I do think that you
know humans are around and you know 300
400 years it's probably because we found
a way to live off of just this one
planet and to diversify a little bit in
terms of where we're able to to support
life but I yeah I think we could
probably make it easier on ourselves by
not picking somewhere that's already
pretty harsh right off of that but you
do think you do it did sound like before
you were optimistic about just building
artificial space stations and living
there do you think that could is a
large-scale possibility yeah and I think
I see a more incremental path to doing
that you don't have to get a lot of
humans to a more distant planet you can
build it in stages yes I can see that
line a little bit more clearly
it does of course the the hard part of
that is that it requires taking a lot of
construction materials up into space
right if you would make something really
big if you want to put a million people
on a habitat that you built artificially
in space that would be quite the
undertaking but I guess you're saying
but at least you can do it bit by bit
yeah and aside from
just having something to stand on on
Mars already you don't really have much
also we don't know if we could use the
actual materials we find there to build
anything so I don't think the situations
in those terms would look that much
different and then yeah and so between
you and me I know that the government
and NASA it's not really between you and
me because we're on the podcast but it's
always looking for a bigger goal you
know should we go back to the moon
should we go back to Mars so it sounds
like you think that neither one of those
obvious goals are the right ones
well the objectives are a little bit
different I think there's still a lot of
science to be done you know you don't
you don't end up in my field working at
a ion engine company without wondering
about the origins of the universe and
why we're here and how planets form so I
think yes of course there's we we don't
understand anything yet and so there's
always reasons to to visit and keep
supporting those types of missions but
if we're thinking about it and the
survival and longevity terms I think
there are maybe other places or other
ways to consider that and what about you
know from watching science fiction TV
shows I I imagine that in the future
we're gonna be mining the asteroids for
all of our valuable raw materials do you
think that's feasible and do you think
ion engines are going to help us you
know take an asteroid and push it closer
to Earth so we can mind it more easily
yes I do
I do think eventually we'll be able to
kind of harness the resources that are
beyond just our own planet absolutely I
mean at what this is a crazy unfair
question but what kind of time scale do
you think that would involve well I
don't I don't even necessarily think
it's impossible to do today it's more of
a question of those resources and
priorities so given how things are
looking today you could say it will
never happen
but but I think technologically there
aren't I don't think there are many
parts of a mission like that at least
for a very you know near-earth object
that are actually infeasible do you
think I mean how much we know about what
is in the asteroids is it really I've
never really understood the extent to
which it would potentially be worth it
in the sense that is it actually easier
more efficient more economical to get
certain materials from asteroids and it
is just from here on earth where we
already are and we can breathe while
we're doing it yeah so it's kind of a
funny you know economical argument where
you know I know someone that was looking
into mining asteroids for things like
platinum but as soon as you start
bringing back that amount of platinum to
the earth and inserting it into the
market all of a sudden the value of
platinum has you know completely
diminished and so how do you justify the
cost of of doing that but I think if
it's a matter of the energy cost of well
it's much more expensive to go back down
to earth to grab this water or to grab
these other materials that we can
harvest that are passing nearby then I
think there are a lot of instances where
that equation works out okay that's
that's good to know
what about so as we're spinning science
fiction scenarios here for science
purposes could we imagine using engines
ion engines maybe like your own or maybe
some other design to capture objects in
space capture a comet that is passing by
I presume very informally that things
that are moving by are just doing so
quite quickly and it would be an
impossibly difficult task to slow them
down and bring them closer but maybe I'm
wrong about that
yeah so in poor space person form I
haven't really done the full trade
through like if you needed to launch all
of the propellant from Earth and to
stage it nearby
until there was something you wanted to
go to and attach to and then push it
closer to earth or do a few experiments
I haven't walked through those scenarios
in in much detail but if we go back to
the science-fiction side of things a
little bit I you know the the asteroid
that passed through our solar system not
too long ago oh mooie-mooie
that was shaped you know suspiciously
like a solar sail that came from you
know way outside our solar system and
this is the first object to pass through
that has ever done that and I absolutely
think we should have done done more with
that one very suspicious and worth
studying I think so yes I hope I hope
our technology can be a part of those
types of missions in the future but I
haven't walked through the full trade
study yeah okay just to be fair to the
audience we should probably fill in a
little bit of the details because this
is amazing I'm glad you pronounce the
name of X I can't pronounce the name of
it
Mulla Mulla is that it yeah yeah this
was this object which is certainly from
interstellar space right it's not
something that was already in the solar
system but it for whatever reason flew
through the solar system and it was not
in the shape of a little tiny ball it
was apparently more or less big and flat
and I know that IV lobe friend of mine
Harvard astronomy professor suggested in
the paper that you know maybe one of the
things it could be is a solar sail you
know
designed by some alien civilization many
other people poo-pooed that idea but I
mean maybe what you're saying is look if
there's even a 1% chance it would
certainly be worth checking that out
yeah exactly and and well I think he
just did a good overview of what it was
but it's um its shape as far as we could
tell looked very peculiar it was shaped
in such a way that it could have
captured photons from the Sun or other
stars to give it the the force it needed
to actually make it to our solar system
and then I think there was something odd
about its trajectory that suggested that
it had had a burst of thruster or force
for some reason and our
our best guests as humans that it passed
by something that heated it up and
caused you know gases to expand and give
it a push but I am still hopeful that
there's more there that that we should
have looked into so I hope we get to the
next one and I hope to be a part of that
I mean don't you think giving the aliens
credit don't you think they could have
designed craft that would have slowed
down and stopped him just zooming by
like spending all that effort to send an
object to another star system and then
only have a visit for a few weeks
well you know I think so I were bringing
into my crazy theories of various you
think about the universe so I think
there's there's got to be other life and
in the sense of other you know
self-replicating molecules so we're not
alone in that there's other bacteria
probably out there but I also I'm not
sure I'm convinced that anybody anyone
else that falls into that life category
has solved the faster than speed of
light travel problem before they were
perhaps hit by a mass extinction sort of
asteroid or something but that let's say
there was other light out there that
generated a lot of knowledge learned how
to do some of these things than we're
hit by some sort of impact part of their
planet broke off and is traveling
through our solar system as lobola
we could probably learn a lot by
studying it so okay if I had to posit
something that's that's where that's
where I landed no I mean I do think I'm
very much an agreement with this the
philosophy that if it's such a high
reward kind of gambled and you know yeah
let's let's take at least explore that
possibility but I don't think that there
is you know a solution to the
faster-than-light problem as a physicist
I think that that problem is not going
away but do you think that nevertheless
and so what if that's true if we don't
ever go faster than light what do you
think is the prospect for we human
beings sending spacecraft to other stars
well I mean Alpha Centauri isn't that
far away I love the breakthrough
starshot ideas about using laters to
send tiny little
sighs spacecraft past that star system
and maybe take pictures and send them
back and I mean you know honestly the
thing I love about that project is that
every single part of it is impossible
today and it's so exciting actually uh
that's I think not everyone is going to
know exactly what that is this was a
proposal
I remember Stephen Hawking was part of
the PR push for it but it it came from
Yuri Milner and the other breakthrough
prize people yeah that's right there are
several initiatives under the
breakthrough prize name and there's
breakthrough listen breakthrough
starshot and there was there was one
other that maybe we can record my voice
as knowing later but this particular one
breakthrough starshot the goal was to
use a gajillion laser too so you know
the to accelerate a tiny spacecraft with
little solar sails to to speed such that
they could reach Alpha Centauri and I
think it was 20 years and so that their
get them closer to traveling at you know
a respectable fraction of the speed of
light and that their signal could come
back in time so that people in our
lifetime could actually start to see
this data coming back but you know the
laser doesn't exist
if those tiny spacecraft were to send
that signal back from that far away you
would need a receiver that's the size of
the distance between the Sun and the
earth capture the data
I just love you know like we know what
needs to be done and none of it's
possible today but I think you have some
of the smartest people in the world
thinking about it which is really
exciting
ya know that that's really great and I
think that you know personally since I
don't think that we're gonna go faster
than the speed of light but I also don't
necessarily think that that should be an
obstacle to go into other stars
you know people say well if we travel at
0.1 speed of light and we'll all be dead
if there's a human being or a set of
people in the spacecraft but number one
you know we could just sleep right we
could do cryogenically suspended people
or number two we could come up with
therapies that extend human lifespans to
thousands of years and I think that
that's those are much even
even though those are nowhere near
technologically feasible now they're
much more technologically feasible than
going faster than the speed of light so
we should just learn to be patient about
these things
yeah I'm right there with you I think
humans in our you know frail biological
forms are the are the main problem there
and so instead you know maybe we send
some stem cells and a robot or something
and then if it happens I see so that no
that that's a new idea so you basically
want to have the ingredients for a human
being and send them into space has been
sending the whole human being yeah or
the other way you could take it is and
kind of getting at what you said you
know various therapies to extend our
lives but really I've started to buy
into the idea that really are our
memories are really only things that
make us kind of unique and so if we can
just figure out how to read and write
those just package those into the
spacecraft and then you don't really
need these animal forms anymore all
right do you know that I think that
makes certainly I would be surprised if
the first probe that we intentionally
sent to other stars had human beings on
it that does seem to be yeah inefficient
way to do it but so what about the other
way around you you hinted just before
that you you think it's very likely that
there is other life out there in the
galaxy but maybe not other intelligent
life because it destroys itself do you
have you have thoughts behind these
probability estimates uh yes I look at
this recently I think the the odds of
getting to a self-replicating molecule
are very high especially given a number
of earth-like planets in the universe so
certainly I think that cropped up all
the time been asking about all the time
means but then you have some other
probabilities that need to occur
depending on kind of the conditions on
the planet like does that like need to
make it out of the oceans on to land do
giant reptiles need to become extinct
before mammals can really take over so
there I haven't really factored those in
but the main problem I see is that to
make it to that point that probability
is probably about the same probability
as that whole planet getting why
out by some sort of catastrophe I don't
know if it's self-made or um from from
the universe Colonel yeah but I
definitely I while I don't think that
will necessarily see another you know
craft from alien planet because you know
Fermi paradox like why why haven't we
already yeah I I do think there are
probably signals or other signs of this
life and whether we need to travel to
that planet to dig it out of the earth
or whether it got some point where it's
able to put off some sort of
electromagnetic signature or something
I'm not sure but I it's I believe it's
out there so yeah so the Fermi paradox
you know the idea that if any time in
the past history the galaxy intelligent
life became spacefaring we should
noticed it a long time ago and we
haven't yet you know I'll be honest my
personal favorite solutions to that are
that either life is really really hard
that it's much harder than we think
because the the biochemistry is not
something that's fully understood yet or
intelligent life technological life is
much harder than we think I think these
are two phase transitions we don't quite
understand yet it seems that you are
more inclined to think that intelligent
life happens with a respectable
frequency but then somehow it gets
destroyed is that fair
I'm out on whether life makes it all the
way to intelligent life I guess I would
say that I probably does with some
lesser frequency but yes then the like
likelihood that it gets destroyed is
even greater and then the tragedy is
that that knowledge is lost so each time
every form is is starting over so if we
could just pass on you know the atomic
theory or something maybe maybe then one
of these civilizations could make it to
light speed travel or at least you know
fire a little bit faster what is your
feeling about the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence as we do
it these days uh well like I said I
you know it's it's possible there are
some sort of electromagnetic signals we
should be able to pick up so I know we
do that type of listening well I think
fairly well and then really I think
there's probably a lot of evidence of
you know life in the the more bacterial
sense but we have to kind of make it to
those other planets or find bits of them
that have been blasted off by impacts or
some things passing your earth to be
able to to determine that so I kind of
think it's just a matter of time okay
that's I mean that's a I like the
optimism there personally I think that
the chances that smart
technologically advanced alien
civilizations are wasting their power by
beaming radio waves out into space it
seems unlikely to me but but you know
again if it's a tiny chance it would be
would change history if it were true so
I've definitely in favor of looking just
in case yeah I I will forever remain
really suspicious of pulsars to like
what are those gotta be something that
we don't understand yet it's always
possible I won't die I wouldn't end
because every thing that interview with
you always
you mentioned that you kind of got into
this game because what do you really
want to do pose to be an astronaut yes
is that still an ongoing ambition yeah
I'll keep applying I've never made it
past the very preliminary rejection
postcard phase and you know to be honest
I don't think I want to be the the first
person to go visit anywhere but I still
have the the dream very much to go do
science in space I mean is it still even
with private rocket launchers sending
people into space is it still the
prospect that people going into space
are going to be officially astronauts or
is space tourism an option for you also
I'm more of I'm not so much of a risk
picker so I would be really into going
to a space station because I needed to
do an experiment that could only be done
in microgravity like that or you know
maybe one of these orbiting stations
will be built in my lifetime and they'll
need people to go figure out how to best
you know design
some part of it or where to put the ion
engines and and so I'll go to help with
that and I do think space tourism will
become a bigger part of our lives and
our discussions going forward but I
probably won't sign up all right well I
hope that they finally come to their
senses and pick you for it but not until
you've finished perfecting these engines
because I think that these ion engines
are definitely going to be a big part of
how we look at the solar system and and
and the earth in your future so the
tally ability thanks so much for being
the podcast that was a fun conversation
yeah Thank You Sean
[Music]
you
[Music]